what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and as you can see i am
in a hotel right now disney has flown me
out to star wars celebration to cover it
so if you're a star wars fan be sure to
look out for some awesome star wars
content coming soon also you can follow
me on my instagram my personal instagram
it's just cosmic warren i'm going to be
taking pictures and vlogging the whole
entire time i'm here the whole entire
weekend but
the point of this video i watched miss
marvel this morning i watched the first
two episodes this is not a review there
will be no spoilers in this no spoilers
at all i can't do an official review
till
maybe next week
not actually sure of the actual day but
this is just my reaction to the first
two episodes um
this is an interesting one i
i basically put this kind of around
hawkeye and i'll explain what that means
i think most people know that i
i kind of hold loki on like a pedestal
that's my favorite um that's my favorite
disney plus show i'm gonna talk about
how this one's different and i think
that a lot of people are gonna like it
and i think that a lot of people aren't
gonna like it but
whereas i feel like with marvel recently
we've kind of had like a split down the
middle with the fandom like people
either really liking something or people
really not liking it i think we're gonna
have
people really liking it people not
liking it and people who are just
sitting there in the middle that go yeah
it's an okay show it's fun it's
entertaining and i can watch the whole
entire thing and yeah i think we're
gonna have that section for this show
and not not to say that we don't have it
for other shows but i think
the majority of people might actually
sit in this kind of middle section for
the show and let me explain what i mean
miss marvel is kind of
tailored to a younger audience
now i'm in my 30s i know a lot of you
don't really know that
i'm in my 30s i'm young 30s and
this is a show that's about a high
schooler
and we've seen that before with tom hall
and spider-man right but it's a very
different tone
this is very much kind of like a high
school
not movie show
and there's some really good things that
come with that and there's some things
that i'm just kind of like
okay
and this i'm just gonna be honest in my
reaction right here uh again it's not a
review but just my reaction to it is
there's a lot of entertaining things
there's connectivity to the mcu which is
something that we didn't get in moon
night and i almost feel like
this is like making up for the lack of
connectivity because one thing that is
actually really cool about this show is
the character kamala khan miss marvel uh
amman does a really great job at playing
her and
what's cool about the character is that
she's like a fan of all of these
superheroes she's a fan of the avengers
so it's pretty much like if you imagine
yourself in real life
with real heroes like kind of going
around you would be like this is like it
would be even more amazing than it is
for us right now as like fans of these
characters who are just in movies like
we could actually be fans of these
characters
who could be real like that's what this
show brings which is a really cool
perspective because she is essentially
like us like these fans but in her world
the heroes are real which is which is
pretty cool but so they have a lot of
easter eggs and they have a lot of
connections and they you know name drop
a lot of different avengers names and
stuff like that it's pretty cool
it's it's pretty cool so there is that
connectivity in the show that moon
knight was missing and i think a lot of
fans are they're gonna really like that
they are going to really like that about
this show
um
the pace scene's okay
again i'm just gonna
be pretty honest about this everyone's
always like oh you love everything
marvel puts out no matter what it's like
not not true i really didn't like what
if hawkeye was okay i
kind of can't even remember the other
stuff right now because my mind is
focused on miss marvel um
but i compare this to hawkeye because i
enjoyed watching hawkeye but to me it
wasn't anything
super special now again if you love
takai i'm super happy for you i'm not
trying to like put down anybody who
liked that that's not who i am i always
want you to form your own opinion about
everything this is just mine this is
just how i feel and hawkeye was
entertaining and there was a lot of
parts of it that i loved but overall i
was just kind of like yeah i'm here for
the red right uh it's fun to watch
uh i'm entertained but nothing like
amazing is happening like even when the
whole kingpin thing came out and
everything like that i was like yeah
that's really really cool but then i was
like but like
cool like um i hope it means a lot for
the future and that's what i hope for
the show i hope it means a lot for the
future and we already know that it does
mean a lot so here's the thing you have
to watch the show no matter what because
the marvel's coming up and
you have to know who miss marvel is
you're going to have to know her
backstory and i'm hoping now again i've
only seen the first two episodes so i'm
hoping that by the end of this show
something really really cool happens and
it connects to the larger picture which
is about to happen which is the marvels
i'm hoping that happens so
this show it has potential
but right now i'm just kind of enjoying
the ride it's entertaining it it's
extremely entertaining at some parts and
i do
chuckle a lot at the things that take
place in the in the show i always want
to say film in the show and there are a
lot of relatable moments and i think
for those of you in high school right
now or not too long out of high school i
think you're gonna really kind of enjoy
a lot of it um whereas to me i just kind
of go yeah like some of that kind of
happened to me in high school or like
yeah i had some friends like that happen
too it's all extremely relatable which
she you know she has her crush and then
she has the best friends and she's
dealing with like her family at home
there are some
kind of more tender moments that are
kind of not sad but yeah kind of sad
where you're like oh i'm like you know
oh
i don't want to spoil anything i can't
spoil anything because the embargo
hasn't lifted yet so that's the best way
i can kind of describe that but um
it kind of reminds me of scott pilgrim
versus the world and you kind of saw
that in the first trailer where you have
like comic things popping on the screen
you know it's like boom pow and you know
like sometimes she'll text and the text
messages will pop up on the screen and
stuff like that that's refreshing and it
reminds me of scott pilgrim versus the
world which is one of my all-time
favorite movies and i am not comparing
this show to scott pilgrim versus the
world i'm not saying it's up there with
it because it's not not a lot of things
are um
but it does give me like
the same vibes almost it's really
cartoony at some points
but they do a really good job actually i
think visually this this show is
actually pretty cool
and i know a lot of people were worried
about her powers and we were wondering
like well why did they change them well
she's not inhuman and i don't know what
the deal with humans are um hopefully
they come into the mcu at one point in
time
but she's not an inhuman in this which
everybody knew because the writers have
been talking about that but uh honestly
you don't have anything to worry about
visually her powers are pretty cool
and you can see how some shots are like
it looks just like it would in the
comics so if you're worried about that
don't worry about that uh they do a
really really good job um
like cgi we've been talking about cgi
for she-hulk i i didn't think any of the
cgi was bad i wasn't paying that much
attention but i didn't think it was bad
and i was it was entertaining like
really it was some things that were
happening with all the easter eggs i
will say that i enjoyed episode one more
than episode two
we'll see
um and the show has introduced some
things that i'm like i wanna know what's
gonna happen like i am intrigued like uh
i'm here for the ride we're gonna watch
the whole thing obviously and i think
it's gonna be a fun time and i think
it's going to be enjoyable but i think
it's gonna sit right there in the middle
but who knows we i i've only seen the
first two four episodes could change a
lot it could have an amazing ending and
that could make it a very very great
show and again the third episode could
really dive into things and it could
pick up a lot and just be a great show
who knows i'm hoping it does but right
now it's kind of sitting there in the
middle with me but
look out for my review next week or
whenever the embargo lifts i will uh
i'll let you all know but click that
bell make sure you have notifications
turned on and
i'm curious to see what everybody thinks
about this because i think again we're
gonna have that middle section and then
people really love it people don't like
it at all i'm curious to see everyone's
reactions so
be sure to subscribe and watch out for
those videos and comment in those videos
when it's finally out what you think of
miss marvel in general
i will catch you all next time woof
[Music]